surprising news about simon cowell and
his recovery from a broken back
is he already close to returning to
america's got talent
we got the latest from his fellow judges
is there any chance that um simon would
pop up for the semifinal virtually
i think so i mean let's give him another
minute it's been one
week and he's already at home i think
that's absolutely incredible
that's giving another week last night
snl's keenan thompson sat in for simon
i didn't love it i actually hated it
that that's the line right i'm pretty
good at simon
oh he was great he's so much fun i'm a
huge keenan fan
but i to be totally honest with you i
miss
that simon factor so every time i look
down the table and i don't see my buddy
i miss it we're not enough for you heidi
and me
yeah you are yeah forget it i didn't
miss time
sophia are you starting to feel kind of
your groove
yeah it's been a little bit hard to get
it for me because every time
something happens something like a
pandemic simon's
gigantic accident but i've had a great
time
tonight 11 acts will whittle down to
five semi-finalists
heidi was blinded by a certain glam
rocker
bona vega he reminds me of david lee
roth
i don't agree with heidi tonight it kind
of felt a little
more flat and that's the beauty of this
show we don't have to agree right heidi
how do you feel to be stuck right in the
middle between the judges overall i
felt pretty positive responses from the
judges i'm just excited that people are
getting what i'm doing and they like it